patient
non
c'est la première fois que
de la réunion
sur le salon maks deux tiers
nous tes parents il ya en stand
600 mètres carrés elle a permis à nous
d'avoir un petit emplacement pour les
vins de la réunion et c'est une grande
opportunité pour nous parce que là
beaucoup de clients qui veut laisser à
l'export en métropole mais quand donc la
découverte que nous l'avait repris le ch
et il a ajouté que et que nous n'avez
tout plein de la réunion pas beaucoup
demandé à nous quand est-ce que nora le
se baladent en métropole et la
maintenance merci je les attrape moi
enfin l'accord d'ici
on a trop intense
et modeste
le monde ce salon là c'est opportunité
aussi plus soit aussi de faire connaître
ce produit est là c'est pas si mal au
cul comme mais aussi une commune que les
magnifiques arrêts non c'est la commune
de 16 ans serait sinon ce sera aussi et
c'est une fiat est aussi de retour à
être ici au salon international
que tu en as je suis allé voir où se
mêlent des états unis ça c'est sûr alors
en tout cas nous on exporte
savoir faire pour que ça nous rend l'air
or c'est ce qui fait le job
stable à 6
participation et à 35,5
l'international est peu présente à nous
un peu
lente alors
un blanc sec
un blanc moelleux et ont posé avec un
gambien créole qui appelle lundi la paix
non pas dans le mauvais sens été
approuvée de l'ours et on l'a dit on l'a
fait après tout ça c'est le derby de la
direction c'est un mystère c'est un
assemblage fin de saison augmenter et
d'alcool locales comme c'est un apéritif
100% local sur l'alcool de faire des
appels unitaires
c'est tout
réfléchir sur l'anneau
brossette comment
s'arrêtant qu'à ça
dans les pas des cours
voilà
en fait on essaye de
perez à nous parce que le client et
habitat est ce que l'on peut faire parce
que
la nature iccn amis des clubs ap ckac
isabelle
les matches
si la hausse de la diva tiens
tous les amis ont offert fermentation
les années peut-être la montée et voir
un type 2 qui lui est associé pour faire
peut-être tout avoué et en même temps
votre main des charentes
l'offre et gascogne et sincère
lui m'a dit personne
les gens adorent se
rien qu'à voir
une autre en retardant
oui acte avant on fait
tout allait beaucoup c'est la
message qu'il voulait
consommer il a des racines en pleine
nature